He knew that it would turn out this way
and headed over there.
What for?
I don't know the details.
But he was looking into something
and found the 'answer' as he calls it.
And he headed out to the scene
for his 'confirmation' like always.
Knowing it was possible he could
be kidnapped during his 'confirmation'.
He should've said something.
He says useless stuff like
he needs to poop or has diarrhea
or constipation,
but never says urgent things.
Ms. Lily?
That guy never believes anything
unless he sees it with his own eyes.
He’s smart, but he doesn’t have
the mentality of someone who is.
His personality is like a nasty
and stupid fifth grader.
No, third grader!
Seriously, I hope he gets his guts
eaten clean and dies!
Your vocabulary for slander is impressive.
Anyway, we have no choice
but to follow the traces.
It's not moldy.
Just as I thought, it's here.
For now, let’s look around
and take things with us.
Got it.
Huh?
Hey, take a look at this.
Is this you, Koku?
Ah, yes.
So cute.
This is Yuna, right?
Hm?
This is Kirisame.
I wonder what this kid
Kirisame wants to do?
There's no meaning to any of this.
He's only doing tedious things.
If we wants to kill the King,
he should just do it.
I don’t understand the meaning
behind involving you or Keith in this.
He’s just adding in extra elements.
He’s endangering his own plan.
I don't get it at all.
I don't think the ‘King’s Life’
is his objective.
Huh?
I think his aim
is to make me kill the King.